parce qu'on voit d'un mauvais oeil les
exercices militaires menées en mer noire
par l'ukraine et par plusieurs pays de
l'otan et le gouvernement russe a
exprimé son opinion sur les événements
mer noire qui ont vu l'entrée dans les
eaux territoriales russes d'un navire
britannique repoussé par des coups de
semonce puis le lendemain l'escort d'un
navire néerlandais
les détails de notre correspondante à
moscou fera d'hoffmann la mer noire et
progressivement transformé par les états
unis et leurs alliés de l'espace de
coopération à une zone de confrontation
a déclaré la porte parole de la
diplomatie russe marya zakharova pour
elle les exercices militaires lancés par
washington qui aide et leurs alliés le
28 juin ont clairement une connotation
anti russe un déploiement militaire de
cette ampleur près du territoire russe
suscite une réaction adéquate de notre
part la zone de la mer noire en fait et
progressivement transformé par
washington et ses alliés de l'espace de
coopération qui se construisait là-bas
en une zone de confrontation c'est fait
délibérément dans l'intention de rendre
instable une rune s'est fait
instable une autre région du monde sous
la direction des etats-unis pour qu'elle
commence à présenter une menace
il ne fait aucun doute que ces
manoeuvres ont une connotation anti
russe évidente
les exercices militaires baptisées ses
brise impliquant quelques 5000
militaires et 30 navires se passe sur
fond de tensions entre la russie et la
grande-bretagne après l'intrusion dans
les eaux territoriales russes le 23 juin
du destroyer britannique defender le
président russe vladimir poutine a
qualifié l'incident de provocation tout
d'abord c'est bien sûr une provocation
une provocation évidente même si vous
avez dit tout à l'heure que le monde
s'est trouvée au bord d'une guerre
mondiale mais bien sûr que non même si
nous avions couler ce navire il serait
difficile d'imaginer
n'est que le monde était au bord d'une
troisième guerre mondiale puisque ceux
qui le font savent qu'ils ne peuvent pas
sortir vainqueurs de cette guerre
je rappelle que l'ambassade de russie à
washington avait exhorté les états unis
et leurs alliés à ne pas pratiquer
d'opérations militaires en mer noire
soulignant que ces manoeuvres
augmenterait le risque d'incident
involontaire